so by the time I got to college I ended
up with four fellowships in neuroscience
I realized that for me graduate school
would be the Auschwitz of the mind I
felt I was in a boxcar on my way to the
end of everything I wanted to understand
in life why is that well because since I
was 12 or 13 years old I wanted to take
all the panoramas the full palette of
the sciences and I wanted to use them
among other things to understand
ecstatic experiences I wanted to
understand how Hitler put together this
performance torchlight parades where 15
guys are walking down the streets
abreast of each other carrying torches
at 10 o'clock at night and people on the
Gunther virulent Van Linden the big
Boulevard are packed so tight but if you
pulled up your feet you wouldn't topple
over because the crowd would hold you up
they were crowded in on either side of
you supporting you and people had a
sense of being lifted out of themselves
and having a transcendent experience and
becoming part of three things I invoke
one tribe I know right one state ein
Fuhrer one leader but it gave them we
all need a sense of being a part of
something bigger than ourselves I wanted
to know how that sense of ecstatic
dissolution into something bigger than
yourself happens do you think that
within Hitler's case that this was an
accident no I think designed this was
yes he did design it he absolutely
decided he knew that he could create
this sort of ecstatic state in these
people you bet
he was an ecstatic and he was preaching
to people to bring them to a state of
ecstasy how did he know all this how did
he know unless he know all this the way
any artist knows how to achieve things
that he may never have seen achieved
before in his life
it's intuition we're all built with
certain super normal responses inside of
us certain gushes of emotion you can hit
if you hit just the right stimulus and
and he hired albert speer to be as art
director so Albert Speer would art
direct these massive events like this
but it was Hitler who would go into a
state of ecstatic preaching as if
preaching in tongues but preaching in
one tongue German hmm and who could
bring that audience to that ecstatic
level
he was disturb you to study someone as
[ __ ] up as Hitler though and look for
the genius in his approach especially as
its you yeah you bet your ass of course
but I figure if Hitler could use this
for evil
the big trick is to understand it and
use it for good and in fact it turns out
that a rock concert has these ecstatic
elements sure in it and you know you
hear about audiences getting off that's
what the people on stage are constantly
trying to achieve that's an ecstatic
stage is this what was fascinating to
you about rock in the first place yes
led you to become a publicist right
because remember if I'd gone to grad
school I would have been giving paper
and pencil tests to 22 college students
in exchange for one psychology credit
now how much was I gonna learn about
mass ecstasy's the forces of history
right in that college cost nothing
fascinating though that you you have
this foresight because for many people
the idea of going to grad school and
becoming a professor like that was the
that was the golden pot at the end of
the rainbow and everybody knew I was
going to be a college professor from the
time I was 10 years old but the closer I
got to it the more I realized that this
is like being put in a sardine can and
having the cam welded over you